nicolas sarkozy qui en reprenant sans
fauteuil de venise de l'intérieur a
inauguré cette première journée en se
rendant à perpignan ont eu lieu de
violents incidents ces derniers jours
discours de fermeté je suis là pour
débarrasser la france des voyous at il
déclaré mais en l'emportant ivan martin
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas changé
à peine nommé le ministre de l'intérieur
se rend à perpignan et renouer avec un
exercice qu'il a toujours affectionné la
démonstration de force mais vous dire
aux jeunes non cela devait recommencer
ma réaction
ce sera très dur non non non voir une
oeuvre en deux heures durant nicolas
sarkozy va marteler le même message
je n'accepterai rien le message il est
pressé keller et pas des comportements
devoyault à perpignan ou ailleurs il
vient rassurer les commerçants dont les
magasins ont été saccagés il ya une
semaine
victimes des émeutes ayant suivi les
assassinats de deux maghrébins d'actions
opra les biens
si j'ai envie encore guerlain et se
retrouveront à la case prison tout de
suite l'amour as you drive affirmé ce
qui fait rigoler je rêve ils retrouvent
leur calme et leur a cruellement défaut
privé le champ couler même s'il a
rencontré les familles des victimes
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas voulu se rendre
dans le quartier saint jacques
là où il ya deux semaines mohamed
belbachir a été lynché par un groupe de
gitans et là où les tensions entre les
deux communautés sont les plus fortes
il veut d'abord que le calme revienne
moi ce que j'aimerais y aller dans les
quartiers qui commit qui communique avec
les deux communautés
j'y parle avec eux et qui voient ici
c'est passé les deux gars qui compagne
enfin parce que l'arrière du mal avant
de partir nicolas sarkozy a exigé que
l'on désarme les deux communautés et a
promis de revenir en septembre prochain